[Applauso]
Daniele ma è vero che voi ciechi avete i
sensi più sviluppati
Ecco questa è una delle domande che più
spesso mi viene fatta quando vengo
inquadrato come particolare esemplare di
non vedente
voglio sfatare un mito Nel senso che non
è che io adesso da qui siccome sono
cieco sento i discorsi che stanno
facendo in centro a Spoleto
o ancora non è che quando ero in coda
per l'udito Siccome il padre eterno ma
visto cieco mi ha detto vabbè ti diamo
appunto un po' di dito in più te ne da
un cucchiaio in più per Per compensare
Diciamo che noi ciechi abbiamo i sensi
più sviluppati Grazie all'esperienza o
meglio grazie alle esperienze allenanti
Io sono Daniele Cassioli sono cieco
dalla nascita Ho 36 anni e nella mia
vita diciamo ho fatto dell'esperienza
allenante veramente un mantra mi sono
dedicato allo sport allo sci nautico Per
la precisione e a furia di dedicarmici
Ho conquistato ho vinto 25 titoli
mondiali
Devo dire però che il titolo più
importante è quello appunto di portare
lo sport ai bambini ai ragazzi non
vedenti tramite l'associazione che ho
fondato perché appunto sono convinto che
l'esperienza allenante a prescindere ci
faccia crescere Ma che cos'è
un'esperienza allenante volete provare
Ok mi aspettavo più entusiasmo comunque
Oh ok Oh Meno male molto bene
Allora vi invito a chiudere gli occhi
e adesso con calma Alzatevi in piedi
Non fate i furbi occhi chiusi eh vi
tengo d'occhio
Allora adesso sempre ad occhi chiusi
fate un giro di 360 gradi su voi stessi
benissimo adesso con calma toccate bene
dietro di voi e sedetevi
Aprite gli occhi e immaginate Adesso
invece ad occhi chiusi non lo farete non
vi preoccupate ma immaginatevi di uscire
magari da questo teatro e ad occhi
chiusi tornare a casa Domattina magari
svegliarvi e preparare la borsa andare a
scuola e andare in ufficio ecco per chi
non vede anche solo girare per strada
col bastone bianco è un'esperienza
allenante per sopravvivere devi
ascoltare le auto non potendole vedere
per evitare che ti schiaccino E quindi
che finisca in tragedia in realtà questa
cosa vale anche per gli esemplari di
vedenti i cosiddetti normodotati gravi
Cioè anche chi vede fa può fare
attraverso l'esclusione della vista
bendandosi dell'esperienza allenanti è
noto per esempio che gli sportivi di
alto livello chi scia per esempio sulla
neve si benda per aumentare e migliorare
la percezione per esempio del pendio la
percezione dell'equilibrio
È interessante questa cosa per
migliorare la percezione dobbiamo
togliere togliere la vista il senso che
più di tutti ci dà informazioni
sull'esterno su quello che che c'è
all'esterno Quindi da qui si capisce che
ognuno di noi può
sviluppare gli altri sensi se lo vuole
anche chi vede
e quindi torniamo a voi vi chiedo ancora
una volta di chiudere gli occhi
adesso se li avete chiusi Alzatevi in
piedi
e Scambiatevi di posto chi avete la
vostra destra va alla vostra sinistra e
viceversa
occhi chiusi mi raccomando
benissimo adesso sempre ad occhi chiusi
toccate con le mani dietro di voi per
evitare guai e con calma risedetevi
Aprite gli occhi e vi invito a
riflettere su quanto la prima esperienza
vi abbia aiutato nella gestione della
seconda siete quasi dei colleghi diciamo
no molto molto bravi
Ecco se ci pensate l'essere umano è
progettato per migliorare per apprendere
per migliorarsi e per crescere l'essere
umano che siamo tutti noi a due
fantastici alleati Uno è il corpo il
nostro corpo e l'altro è il cervello la
testa Diciamo il nostro corpo Fa un
sacco di cose senza che noi ce ne
accorgiamo per esempio respira per noi
oppure suda
digerisce se il nostro corpo fosse
un'azienda e le cellule fossero dei
dipendenti Noi saremo di fronte
all'impresa più di successo e più
efficiente probabilmente mai trovata mai
vista prima se il nostro corpo fosse un
condominio e le cellule fossero i
condomini staremo vivendo veramente
nella nel contesto più armonioso che si
sia mai incontrato
e oltre al corpo c'è un altro alleato
incredibile che appunto è il cervello il
cervello Il mio cervello ammesso che io
ce l'abbia
ha scelto per necessità di dedicare are
intere che sono usate per vedere che voi
usate per vedere all'udito al ascolto
quindi che cosa succede che ha una
capacità di orientare tutte le risorse
che ha in virtù delle nostre esigenze e
se ci pensate questa cosa è
straordinaria e si chiama plasticità il
nostro cervello è plastico quindi è in
grado di adattarsi e questo lo succede
anche a voi succede a chiunque di voi
chi Per esempio è appassionato di cucina
sta dedicando parti del suo cervello per
maneggiare bene degli utensili per
memorizzare le ricette già per tutto ciò
che è la sua esigenza di quel momento
chi di voi è un bravo professionista mi
auguro tutti usa il proprio cervello per
mettere a frutto le competenze le
proprie competenze e le competenze che
ha crescere e migliorare
poi arriviamo noi
con la parte diciamo cosiddetta la
ragione No la consapevolezza la
cognitività questa cosa non fa per me
Te l'avevo detto che su sta roba ero
scarso eh Sarà capitato almeno una volta
a ognuno di voi di dirsi questa frase
succede tanto anche a me E quante volte
mi viene detto guarda voi disabili avete
una forza che noi non abbiamo Ecco mi
spiace per voi ma questa forza ce
l'abbiamo tutti
chiudete di nuovo gli occhi Vi giuro che
l'ultima volta eh
e Adesso piano piano Alzatevi di nuovo
in piedi
adesso
datevi un 5 con il vostro compagno di
posto col vostro vicino Scambiatevi un 5
vai occhi chiusi eh
Ok se non abbiamo l'acero contusi Vi
chiedo piano piano di risiedervi
Occhio a dove vi sedete
e riaprite gli occhi
adesso siete dei professionisti
anche chi di voi non è riuscito a
trovare la mano del compagno Sicuramente
si sarà preso conto che è migliorato un
pochettino ad occhi chiusi quindi vedete
che anche voi in 10 minuti avete
allenato un pochettino gli altri sensi
Ecco se io adesso dovessi chiedervi che
cosa serve che cosa ti serve per essere
un genio
ognuno di voi Io compreso ognuno di noi
penserebbe ad aggiungere mi servirebbe
più intelligenza
mi servirebbe più
tenacia mi servirebbe più quoziente
intellettivo
e invece forse a volte non è aggiungere
che ci aiuta perché quando abbiamo
aggiunto delle cose per esempio i
navigatori satellitari adesso che li
abbiamo Nessuno si ricorda più una
strada a memoria
quindi a volte Forse più che aggiungere
bisogna fare un passo indietro
e togliere qualcosa diciamo così
noi disabili lo facciamo per scelta la
mia storia un po' ve la raccontato E se
non vi basta la mia storia Posso
raccontarvi la storia di Leonardo la
storia di Nicole e la storia di Riccardo
tutti i bambini non vedenti che grazie a
una mancanza Hanno sviluppato un
rapporto col suono incredibile e sono
musicisti a sorprendenti e quindi chi ha
una disabilità toglie per necessità
mentre per tutti noi per tutti voi
Questa può essere una grande opportunità
un'opportunità straordinaria
io vi ho avvisato ve l'ho detto adesso
la scelta ora è vostra
[Applauso]